大家好，欢迎大家，这是
主动推理嘉宾流 28.1，现在是
2022 年 10 月 14 日。
今天我们将听取和
讨论 Giovanni Rolla 的重新认识理性，
所以 Giovanni
非常感谢大家的加入，非常
期待这次演讲和
讨论 谢谢，
谢谢，那么很高兴在
几个月前收到你的邀请
，我很高兴
能有机会在这里讨论我的
工作，
嗯，我会放弃你的要求，
我们的建议，我正在介绍
这个 几年前我写的论文
，嗯，当我们在后台谈论时，
我有我已经改变了几次主意
，自从我发表那篇论文以来，我将在演讲中明确这一点
，但我
很高兴 尽管如此，还是有机会
在这里展示这个视频并
与世界分享，所以我很
高兴，
所以我们将讨论
重新认识理性，这就是
这就是
行程 我正在考虑
向您介绍，所以首先我将
谈论理性和
无内容的认知，然后我将介绍
我的观点，我称之为完全
不活跃的理性和安全词，
关于代理和熟练的互动
以及推理和理性，它们
与一对夫妇关系密切 反对意见的
第一个是
我在场的任何东西都是真正的
自由主义者，在某种程度上过于自由它
包含了太多
，我认为
您最感兴趣的第二个反对意见是
它是否与效果兼容
我们的预测编码中的预测
过程当然是在设施中，它
靠近中央的两辆汽车
以产生积极影响，
所以
这是
抱歉，我对此事的最初想法
是传统上非常
正统 对理性有看法
嗯，据我所知，
这实际上是一个假设，
理性必须在他们
的推理中 当且仅当存在支持 Bure 的推理时，我相信 B 在
动作 a 中是理性的
根据这部传统
电影，如此相信和理性行事的启发式方法
需要满足某些形式标准
，正如我所说，在我看来，这在
很大程度上是关于
在推理方面定义理性意味着什么的假设，
所以如果理性需要推理
和 如果推理涉及
根据某些正式基准对信念进行评估，
那么理性意味着
认知内容，
其中我认为内容具有最低限度
的准确性条件
能够是
对或错，或者在更
重要的概念中是真还是假，
所以 这里的想法是理性
必然涉及内容它涉及
信念 推理和比较或
抱歉现在更新
一个软件更新我很抱歉
我的窗口中有一个弹出窗口，所以
嗯
，我认为这是
关于理性的标准观点
，
如果是这样的话，理性必然
涉及 内容它非常
适合古典认知主义或
一般认知主义，
这是一种观点，即组合
至少对于某些
认知主义者来说必然涉及表象内容，当然它也可能
涉及概念内容，但
至少具有表象内容
准确性条件，
但这种经典观点不太好，
它不能很好地适应
完全不活跃和具
身的认知，我在这里，呃，不是专门考虑
古德温·缅因在最近的书中的激进和激进主义，但我
认为它也挑战了其他
没有被呈现为激进和
积极的观点，但当然它们与激进和积极的观点共享一些
核心租户 sm
我们可以称它们为 uh 从根本上体现
的认知观点，例如
um 与 Ezekiel
Powell 或 Berman
感官模型生活所提出的观点，你也有
Gallagher 在他
2017 年的书中的各种不作为，还有我的意思
是 Tony kimero 在他的观点 2009 年出版的关于
生态心理学和动力
系统的书，它们都有共同的租户
，在这里我知道这是非常
有争议的，但我将这些
观点视为从根本上体现的
认知观点，但我特别
关注激进和积极的
烹饪观点
他们都说，不是识别
是具象的内容，这
在某种程度上说，我们可以想到基本的
无内容认知形式
或无内容水平的基本认知水平，
它通过
对一个人的环境的积极探索和
超越激进和激进主义而出现 我们的
意思是
这可能是这个想法可以
在掌握感觉运动参与方面兑现
一个知道的问题 - 如何
知道如何与
周围环境互动，而不是知道周围的
事物，所以这
很明显是 Paulo 和
他的同事以及呃 kimero
在他们的书中所做的，呃激进主义和激进主义
有一定的歪曲倾向 感官
模型参与 感官模型方案
等等
，
但是最近的发展我认为已经
合并了，所以这是
对这个想法的要点的使用，
所以如果我们将
反刍或激进和激进主义的激进体现观点
与经典燃料结合起来
我们所拥有的理性是角度
描述如下
的东西激进主义是这样一种观点，即
认知基于对世界的祈祷理性
理解，这种理解基于
对现实生活情况的感觉运动获得
，他解释了这些，呃，这种
预先的想法
嗯
，根据海德格尔的思想，
与世界的关系只能是一个植根于
p 的理性理解。 实习生在表演和
练习中的不活跃是通过身体来调节
的，所以这里似乎隐含的
是，与表演和练习不同，
理性
实际上并不是一种非常
基本的结合水平，所以
这就是当我们
为植根于主动和实践的基本认知水平腾出空间，
并将其与更高层次的
组合分开，它们通常
是理性的幸运经典的轨迹，
所以
总而言之，这个想法是
有争议的认知或
通过感官出现的基本认知 运动
参与不是理性的，
所以感官的现代参与，但是
不能从理性的角度评估多产的美德
只有认知的内容
高级组合可以是理性的
定义，
例如在信仰中表达，
最近很好，这就是 我
没有在纸上提到，但这
是我隐含的动机
作为来自心灵哲学的人，对这个主题
的理解是关于给定神话的想法，
至少当时我认为它的一个版本，嗯，我
被一位评论家正确地说服了不要
触及这个主题
在我最初的介绍中非常复杂，
但在我看来，如果我们将
基本认识与理性的思想
和行动分开，并且我们不指向
井，那么我的意思是
这两个层面之间没有交集，似乎
激进主义和激进主义和 嗯，类似的
观点将致力于
神话不被卖方普及和
麦克道尔的节制作为
我头脑中专横的领域的一个问题，
所以这似乎是我认为
[音乐]
一个哲学上有趣的问题，
但它不是什么 呃
，在论文的最前面，我
在这里的隐含动机是解释
我们如何通过感官现代参与将无内容或
基本的认知水平
与比率结合起来 本质如果
你不能，似乎呃有
某种给定的
东西在我们的心智图景中没有被完全解释，所以这是我
想要的我仍然想尝试
更清楚地探索这个直觉，但我
没有 没有
提到
这个，
但是我认为有一些东西可以
说明为什么我今天要展示的
是我认为这是一种方式来消除
这种
对既定神话的指责，
所以我们如何才能重新构想理性我的
意思是 我认为为了避免这个
问题并避免我们有
两个完全分开的层次的想法，
其中一个更高的层次是
经典理性的轨迹，而
在它下面还有什么不是理性的，我
认为这个想法是拒绝
理性它 必须定义，否则
必然需要推理
不需要仍然构思，
但挑战变成了提出一个
积极的
建议，即如果不是推理，理性是什么
，这里是 Susan H  urley 在一篇
论文中说，我的知识是唯一
关于这个主题的知识，我认为她当时
也很关心
给定的神话，他是
从这里的一个长引用 phenomide 我
读它是理性 可能
来自不同水平层
之间的抑制促进和协调的集中层次关系的复杂系统，
每一个都是动态的和环境
位置的理性，以
水平或模块化的术语重新构想呃我不
知道她是否必须使用这个
术语但是 无论如何，这就是她
选择表达的方式 它与环境可持续地
相关 它
不仅取决于
在输入和输出之间进行调解的内部程序，
例如整个有机体
或垂直边界
中央认知模块的内容，而是
取决于 专用世界之间的复杂关系，
涉及
监控和响应 n 特定方面
的层 自然和社会环境
以及神经网络，并
从他们的反应中减少他们的反馈
据我所知，这是最早的
一个人从事非主动方法
的案例，显然更
通常与 avano 的工作有关
，它也是一个激进主义者，但
在与激进主义和激进主义不同的方法中
，这是
我写那篇论文之前最早的，据我所知
，最清晰
的理性建议是
用本土术语重新构思的，但这并不是
在她发表后获得牵引力的东西 我的知识
实际上从那时起我并没有看到太多
，总结一下这个想法是我们
必须改变解释性焦点
，即理性不仅仅
被认为是一个内容，涉及
它所在的提案中的容量
或涉及增加的世界的世界
它是否从根本上体现它
取决于身体形态和行为
以及有机体如何定位和
行为 在那种环境中，这个想法将
是最低限度的死，所以这就是我所说的
彻底不活跃的
理性，嗯，
到目前为止，这是一个非常松散的定义，即亚洲人
在人类
与她的环境保持熟练的互动，
协调她的
认知能力的情况下，理性地行事 根据
约束
和固定站的环境条件，当然这
有时需要适应
不可预见的情况，
核心直觉是
这样的，将这种
激进和积极理性
的想法与苏珊赫尔利在
2003 年的一篇文章中的另一个想法进行比较是很有趣的。 她说
表演的原因，她
认为，表演的原因可能与上下文有关
，她反对 呃
Gareth Evans 的普遍性约束
，这是对实际理性岛屿的想法的辩护，
所以她仍然将理性
本质上视为相关的东西 在
这里推理，但这种
推理是有限的 d 从实际
情况
来看，所以如果与我一开始谈到的传统观点相比，这是一个非常进步的观点，
但仍然比
我在这里试图发展的更保守，
所以我认为另一件事必须是，呃
，这是最前沿的 建议
是，理性意味着代理和
自治，因为有机体所做的某事或仅
某事可以
说是理性的权利，
因此使用这些来自
自治和激进主义阵营的想法以及
如何玩家的理论是
自治系统，例如 Roomba
不可能是理性的，因为它不是
代理它不是自己行为的作者，
它是由外部代理设计的
，以某种方式工作，所以
严格来说它不是一个国家，所以这
就是我要划清界限的
地方 例如，你不能将理性归于 Roomba 是没有意义的
，为此
我使用了 DiPaolo 和其他人的自主性和
适应性的概念，你
有一个 还有最近的一本书，图像
四感官模型生活和
2005 年碗里的那篇著名论文，他
谈到了适应性
，以设置他
对俄罗斯意味着什么的非常普遍的限制，
因此自治系统被
认为是不稳定的网络
不稳定的过程网络，因为
组织和物理边界是
由系统本身产生的，
系统不断地维持它自己的
生存能力条件，这就是
所谓的意义建构，其中
系统探索
了有
利于它的自我维持的环境环境条件和
避免那些对它有害的东西，
所以这就是我理解
的最普遍的方式，即他们
对理性存在的情感约束
，它必须是一个自治系统
，这里有趣的
是保罗的适应性概念，但
第四是
有机体通过自我生产来改善自身条件的能力
h 内部
结构变化，
因此它涉及
对内部变化的监控和调节，
以便选择最佳
可行的行动方案。
不一定致力于
推理和内容，
因此代理是通过
行使
情境能力来实现的
或表明其合理
性，有机体越理性，
它就越适合处理其
环境，我们已经预见到了
情况，
并且在这样做的过程中，有机体增强了
自身与环境之间的持续交流，
这对其生存和 这
是非常
自然的理性思维方式
主要是
为了生存而增强变化的能力
这是
这里的总体想法，
所以正如我之前所说的，我想要推理
我不想用推理来必然地提交理性
，这
就是根本不活跃的理性的
全部意义，但我 不想将
推理排除为以前的理性
组合，所以我要说的是，
它不是由推理定义的，但
不是，它不排除
推理，我认为推理将被认为是
一种特殊或特定的理性
代理模式 这是我们
人类所独有的知识，
但它不是理性的定义特征，
所以为此我呃，为了解释
这个想法，我记得胡图和土星
是如何在 utani 最近的书中的论文之间
解释的
高度认可的出现 这个想法是，
能够参与
认知内容最终取决于
社会文化嵌入
，内容完全认知
来自社会 当
一个人参与社会
文化实践时，
他们接受了更古老的认知
能力来处理符号，并且通过
这样做，他们
在一个漫长的文化适应过程中，
当然
他们变得能够参与呃
符号协调，这不是
内部的 特定的表征，因为
它是公开的，它不是
传统意义上的心理表征，
但它具有符号认知的特征，
没有对
内部表征或心理
表征的承诺，
因此在最一般
意义上的理性行动是这样一种观念，即一个人的熟练
行为 有机体在呃
是一个有机体
在其环境中的熟练行为，它
取决于具体能力的协调，
而如果一切顺利，推理
当然被理解
为理性的内容，因为我的特定
理性模式推理是一个熟练的
行为 社会
文化中的有机体
环境当然是我们环境的一个更具体的方面
，它
取决于这种文化基础或内容的协调，这些
内容涉及
在人类系统发育尺度上较新的
能力，这是最大的
想法，这是 我认为
是积极的部分，这里
是我想谈的
第一个反对意见是，这是一个非常自由的
观点，非常，
嗯，很好，它包含了太多的
人会说，因为如果理性行动
归结为协调 对于
认知能力，理性
是渐进的，因为一个有机体
可能或多或少地精通其
环境相互作用
，而拒绝是根据
根本不活跃的理性进行的，许多
有机体在利基中实现并维持一种
适应性行为，并
取得不同程度的成功
嗯，有人可以为自由党唱理性
和积极的激进和积极的
理性，这是
我亲自听到的一个反对意见
，我一直很努力，因为我认为
这是一种很好的表达方式，
即使钉子在
这个观点上是理性的，我必须
说我愿意购买 钱包
嗯，是的，它比
传统观点更自由，当然它是
有意的，但我不认为
这本身就是我认为的问题，
这里的积极部分是它
保留了人类的程度差异
比其他动物更理性，
仅仅是因为我们能够
在各种各样的动态环境中执行各种各样的动作，
这远远超出
了我们所知道的任何其他动物，
所以回到这个钉子的例子，
这个钉子可以 执行一些复杂的
动作可以从一个点移动到
另一个点它可以寻找食物和
住所等等，但是如果
你用南方包围这个钉子，它们的能力有限
，例如它注定要死
另一方面，反驳和人类
他们更具适应性，
能够动态处理许多
不可预见的情况，所以嗯
，我对这个反对意见的回应是，
是的，
嗯，它非常自由，但这
不是问题，如果
那样的话 如果它
在动物如何处理它们的环境之间存在程度差异的空间，
那么这是另一个对象
反对，我认为它可能是
你最感兴趣的一个，那么
你知道的是 12 预测处理
似乎一直暗示着推论和内容
，
但首先我必须警告你
和观众，
在我写这篇文章的时候，这篇
论文对这种
将行动主义和
预测编码或预测
处理相结合的可能性更加乐观，呃 我认为这里有一些
重要的观点，但是
Olu 和 Evan Thompson 以及 Randy beer 最近的这篇论文
，他们呃他们
提供了对呃 th 的批判性评估
尝试主要结合
自由能原理和
不活跃和
自传理论，所以我现在
大多被这些论点说服，但我
认为这里有一些有趣
的比较点，
尽管如此，我们的预测
代码中的预测过程和呃 在我写作的时候
，直到今天仍然
在认知科学中
风靡一时
在这些观众中，您知道
竞争被理解为
在双向狭窄层次结构中发生的错误最小化过程，
因此
您可以
为较低层的活动生成内部模型，该模型
可以预测险恶刺激的远端原因，
这是一个 自上而下的
过程和最小化
预测和
当前刺激信号之间的差异，由
um 占用先验
是过程的底部，
所以这里当然是主动推理
，例如，
在非正式的你知道克拉克的正式术语中
，有机体移动其传感器
的方式相当于我们这一代人积极寻求的方式，
从而产生它们相当的感官后果 他们的
大脑期望
这是理解积极
影响非常正式的术语的一种方式，但我
认为它可以完成
工作，如果看起来我的存在有问题，大脑会推断
接收到的刺激的预期来源
谈论
所以他投票阅读预测
处理，它使用
产品偏差和推理
权，例如，
感知
主义者的过程与
增殖和上下文自上而下
效应的理性更广泛的偏见过程是分开的，我觉得每个中间
水平的 处理这件事引起了我的
注意，克拉克一直
在谈论理性，
但这是一个 n 推理类型的
理性
和普遍的影响者推理
似乎暗示了无所不在的内容
，然后预测处理
似乎与根本不活跃的
理性不相容，但是当时
有，我认为我们仍然可以在
其中争论一些没有
非 - 痔疮和
预测处理
的阅读，例如，第一步
将是使用通货紧缩的预测意义，
即在 2013 年的一篇短文中理解客串，
但第四步，其中
两个或多个变量
的值 covari 或值是可靠的，所以
值 1 允许观察者推断
另一个的值，这里的
推断发生在
观察的水平上，而不是在一个远
变量推断另一个的值，
所以我
认为内容在眼中
旁观者 解释
我们选择的审查员如何
近似于此处理解的内部预测的人
通货膨胀的感觉可以
用推论和偏见的术语来描述它，
所以这就是我如何看待
布鲁诺论文关于 4 000 的想法
，如果我没记错的话，它的
标题就像大脑
不是科学家，论点在
我们正在预测的这个大方向，
科学家们如何将大脑活动解释
为大脑本身的一个特征，就好像它
在预测和推断这种更
强大或更重要的感觉，
所以我在这里想说的是
主动推理，然后我使用双重 并且
说双重忘记了英语的名称
对不起，
这不是根据根本不活跃的推理的字面意义，
呃理性是没有武装
的共同导向行为的效率，
代理必须以某些方式行动，
以便他的 他或她的状态
更有效地实现结果，成本更低，
这并不
意味着生成模型
本身显示和执行
预测推理的主张更具争议性 es 这是对预测处理的一种非常
通缩的解读
，以提供
这种具有激进和积极
理性的组合
，这是 2018 年的一篇论文中的
开场白
，它并不认为
有机体具有
其生态位的内部表征模型，
因为它
如果你愿意的话，这些是认知工作的模型吗？相反，
有机体是一个模型，它是因果关系
和统计规律反映在
某些环境中，反映了一些
表型，它是一个模型
，
这与最近
我和我的同事 notifica 的事情有关 一直在
谈论有机体如何
根据
激进主义创造一个世界的想法，这是一种想法，即有机体
和环境在
历史上被称为确定的，因此
在流动遗传尺度上，这可以
通过利基
构造的想法来解释 一个
有机体在其环境中是活跃的，它会
促进变化，如果它们
足够稳定 它们可以被其
后代继承，这些变化提供了新的
进化压力压力
，这些压力引导了它的进化路径
理性行动意味着
通过某种方式预测
和最小化
来实现与环境
的熟练接触
无意义预测及其最小化
涉及世界参与方式中输入的选择和
交互性的协调，
这
正是激进和积极人格的主要主张，
所以我认为在
某种程度上，预测处理不是
呃敌人，而是
而不是这个想法的谎言而不是呃
到达而是c 我们还有其他
的兼容性问题，我
在这里没有涉及到，但这就是
我今天想到的所有内容，
谢谢，
很棒，非常感谢，很好，
很酷，
对那些正在观看现场直播的人来说很有趣，请
随意 写下任何问题我会
收集我的笔记，让我们开始
讨论
好吧，
首先再次感谢你的
谈话
，关于你如何
在
你目前的职位上提出这些问题以及你
在这个领域的兴趣如何发展的一些背景，因为
有 这么多有趣的想法，我
只是想更多地了解你
是如何得出这个框架的，并加强你的
观点，
好的，谢谢，这是一个很好的
问题，因为你并不经常
可以探索这个背景，
这很重要，所以我当时是
我想我当时正在写我的博士论文，
那可能是 2007 年之类的，嗯，我
在争论
理性必须是
最终与世界有关的东西 有一种
思考的倾向，即使
我告诉你，正如我向你展示的那样，在
与某些人的具体化时期中，
它本质上需要是世界，
涉及诸如行动和实践
等等
，当然还有感知，但理性
仍然存在 类似于可自然化的
概念之类的东西，
它
不能以某种方式按比例缩小，
例如可以
通过某种动态参与来解释的感知
等等，
所以当时我想得很好
也许这是
一个膝盖问题，因为
在其他
其他情况下，它被认为是暗示，
如果它没有
以某种方式表达出来以提供
与专业组合的某种契合，
那么感知是给定的
，这是给定维度的神话
一开始，我想
，也许这
有点像是
给定的在积极认知上工作的神话，
但这不是我认为的
不是致命的，因为我们不能原则上
争论，而
不是解释步骤感知和
其他涉及概念等的基本组合形式，
也许我们
可以
从另一个方向争论，尝试
在更非自然化的
水平上缩小
理性
所以这就是动机，
这是一个漫长的审查过程，我
相信我的第一个
论文的第一个版本，观众非常我
认为他们完全正确我
毕竟支持了这个建议，但
他非常呃
他们 非常坚定地参与
其中，我认为这是更好的，
因为它是另一种文学，它
是另一种，呃，很多参考文献
通常不会与
激进主义和身体识别进行对话，而且
很难仅仅把
以同样的方式推进我的论点，
所以这是我划掉的东西
，我没有对
那个系统考虑太多，但我认为这是我
想要的东西 回过头来，也许，
甚至可能有人
在过去几年中这样
做过 所以我认为
我们可以我们应该的东西我的意思是呃能够
探索但是没有什么
东西在论文的最前沿
但是我有这个想法来谈论
闪烁的每一个意义上的理性
同时 当我读到很多
关于呃
从哲学的角度打电话给他
的时候，我当然不像我说的那样
非常精通这种方法的技术细节
和形式，
但我对
那里的哲学后果很感兴趣，我
想得很好 也许这里有一些东西可以
比较，因为正如克拉克的
引文所示，
你可以一直谈论
理性，嗯，这是我想要发展的东西，
但不是从认知主义的观点来看，
但不是从根本上体现的电影，所以
这就是背景
真棒谢谢你能不能
描述一下
什么是给定的神话这个神话出现的背景是什么
以及在
提出给定的神话之后我们该去哪里
因为我认为它是一个概念 你
编织了，所以它是什么，
好吧，所以在给予它的中间有几个可能的给予，这
取决于你对我的哲学的风格，
但最经典的是在先前
的心灵领域中，将
感知的内容给予
以一种我们有某些输入的方式理性地祈祷，这些
输入是大脑刚刚接收到的
，大脑会解释它，所以
卖家不同的卖家以
呃描述他的呃这个问题而闻名，这个
问题不仅增加
了心灵的燃料，而且还 对于理性主义者，
但另一方面，理性
通常被视为
给定的理性直觉，也就是说，存在
某种程度的认知，
呃，它说不清楚。  s 给定的，或者正如有些
人所说的被培养给定的，
但在某种程度上，存在这种
认知水平，并且大脑必须
对其进行解释，但如果以这种方式给予
它，它就没有接触
点，任何东西之间都没有交叉点
无论头脑做什么，以及这种基本
的统治水平，所以我的想法是
避免被指控致力于
给定的神话，但这
在本土主义文学中并不是明确的，
但
它似乎是
我的意思是在这种比较中可能会发展，
但这不是不是从
那里不清楚而是
解决它们的一种方法让
Givens说感知内容
在本质上已经是概念性的，
例如Joe McDowell如何
记住更多的是你知道一种
看法呃笑话是带有
字幕的你并
像你一样解释世界但是呃
我认为一种或另一种方式
是揭开你的神秘面纱你知道理性 并且
组合的上层尝试并
尝试在不提交它们的情况下将它们考虑在较少的
内容中进行分析
，所以严格
来说，它具有与基本组合水平分离的内容水平，这是
我认为这样做的一种方式
，并且 理性似乎是
做到这一点的一个关键概念，因为
它通常被假定为
完全是人类的东西，并且
与推理有关，如果是
这样，那么理性就不能指导行动
，当然，如果行动
本质上是无内容的 因此，如果理性
是一种本质上是满足的感觉，而反应本质上是无内容的，
那么你可以没有
这个
呃，这两个领域之间的这个呃交叉
，这
是我想避免的，但正如我
告诉你的那样，它变得如此难以
以
足够清晰和笼统的方式表达这种观点是
，根据我们的审稿人的建议，我把它
删掉了，
我仍然在想我 t 但是没有什么我
没有发展出一条正确
的论据线，
比我能做的更清楚地处理它，因为我只是
用非常笼统的术语做的
很酷，你与理性相关的一些词
是适应性
和熟练度，所以你看到了什么
作为一种生物功能的理性和适合度的关系
是的 是的 好吧
我认为这是一种内在的
关系 真的
我们
谈论理性
是呃某些物种的特征还是不是
个体的特征我认为健身是这里的关键概念之一，
将
其
视为这种呃理性行为的结果，
所以虽然我没有说我没有
把它放在论文中的那些问题上 我
认为可以这样想
o
如果
它还没有本能，那么每个
生物体都接受这个结果 处理
呃敌人不断变化的环境，
但是很好，这是拥有
非常
自由的理性进步概念的代价，
这是
它的结果我相信
所以你说过健身
是理性的结果行为是否
有其他后果或 我们如何
从外部认识到理性，
而不是仅仅说好
蚁群正在蓬勃发展，以至于
它是理性的，它是适应
展览机构的，所有这
一切都是这样一个通货紧缩的
理性概念，所有现存的
人类和事物 否则仅
由它描述，或者是否有一些
结果可以用来解开
例如理性或非
理性行为与仅
由 su 反映的后果 生存和
健身
很好，我必须非常
仔细地考虑这个问题，因为我
不想轻视这个概念，
因为一切都是事实的 IPS
认为，呃，在特定情况下，一个人
可以呃确定我
与个人平等的国家，
嗯，在那个利基市场中自我维持，所以
在个人层面，特别是
好的，这是一个决定性的某些
行为，可能分类
者在某种程度上是非理性的，他们 呃
对生存有害，但是
呃在物种层面上，
以这种方式争论更困难，因为
要确定这种行为或
后果，但我认为
为了不轻视理性的想法，
并说好一切
生活是一个因素，你必须
确定这种不利于生存的特定行为
，
所以在蚁群的情况下，我
可能不知道
欢迎入侵者将是一种
不利于
生存的行为，因此
我不知道我不知道这是不是，
这是一种不可能的思考方式，
我必须更清楚地思考，
但
我的 仔细
哦，非常有趣，您
在演示文稿中引入了这个答案，
就像 Eco Evo
Devo 所做的那样，从更生物学的
角度来看待生态位
构造如何弥合
较慢的系统发育过程和更
快速的发育过程之间的差距，
嗯，所以 这种
嵌入式和多尺度考虑
如何与内容
概念相关，例如内容将
在一个主体中本地化，还是内容
分布在实体之间，或者
理性分布在实体之间
，我们如何识别
理性的轨迹？ 还从您提供的报价中
调用了 um 水平和模块化
概念，
所以我们如何识别显着性
时空尺度和
感兴趣的系统
哦，我不知道我不知道我是否可以
完全回答这个问题，但在我看来，
如果我们谈论的
是内容，例如内容作为
准确性 象征性
思想的条件 我认为幸运的是，我们不得不
说它不是本地化的，
它是公开共享的，
所以你可以说，
嗯
，这样做的一个结果是，
可以考虑不同
的推理模式，这些模式已经
成为信息
站点 在不同的时间等等，你可以
看到他们为内容信息制定了不同
级别的不同呃规则
，我认为这是
合理的说内容
是本地化的，
呃你怎么能说它分享
你知道的细节的数量
只是出于理性，我认为
如果它符合这些，则可以[音乐]识别特定
行为 有机体与其环境之间的相互作用
它的利基所以
我们可能可以在这里给出不同的答案
作为理性和内容我
愿意说
组织的内容
不是发生在头脑
中的东西以某种方式
分享 其他人的数量，这是
我的哲学
至少从 60 年代以来就一直存在的东西，
我的哲学家一直在争论
内容是外部个体化的想法
，嗯，我认为这是它
的视频之一 例如 Hillary Putnam
和 Tyler Burge 等人认为
心理内容在社区层面或社会层面是个体化的，
但另一方面，他们认为
理性原则上可以
在特定行为中个体化，
但这取决于个人的
目标和 它所居住的利基
等等
，当然这里有实际变量
，对于识别行为也可能很重要
无论是理性还是
不好，
谢谢，
嗯，一个真正
困扰我的短语就像知道如何不知道这
也许是你工作中的一个基点，
并且专注于那个动作，所以我只是
想
听听你在编织时是如何行动和练习的
他们今天在这里，这些术语是如何
处理
的，今天的事情与
行动、实践和
技术的处理有何不同
我
认为，
嗯
，嗯，这是
一种非常现代哲学的趋势，
但它在认知科学的第一波浪潮中非常有影响力，
将感知视为
对环境进行分类
并提供离散的能力。
环境方面的描述，例如
，感知
到我知道杯子在我的左边
是一个知道
有搜索这些属性的东西的问题
我的左边，这是一种呃知道
那种
对世界的命题态度所以
呃我认为
激进主义和
生态心理学也很有趣
，以至于他们从一开始就回忆起美国
的实用主义 本
世纪将
感知视为不是对世界上
这些伟大的属性进行分类的问题，
而是将其视为揭示行为的
可能性
，如果我们用诸如知识
之类的流行术语来解释这一点，
我们将不会”
不是说知道
曲线在我的左边，而是知道如何
拿起杯子，
如果我想喝一杯
咖啡，或者如果我想把它用作
镇纸它将具有不同的
无声属性，尽管我认为这是非常重要的
，
但
我认为激进主义和生态
心理学以及其他具体的认知观点
在 shif 中已基本成功 把这个讨论讨论到这
一点我认为在更
传统的认知科学中你仍然
有这样的想法，即
通过
描述环境的方式来感知有机体有机体，
这是我认为
更传统的
预测处理解读使呃清楚
就像你在
推断刺激的来源而不是
在呃和不是这不是我的意思是
这更容易接受
大脑或认知
系统
知道世界是
某某环境是某某，而不是
说议程系统知道如何
与世界互动，我
相信活动家和生态
心理学家试图提出的观点是
，并致力于预测
编码和自由能原理
等是为了表明这些概念这些
框架可能是一个最小的想法，
即 kubernetes 系统知道如何
参与它知道如何参与 ge in
environment in a way it doesn't need to
be read inboard summary
that the Kindle system is infering
that the world is so所以我认为这是
一种解释方式，但从哲学上讲，
如果你在开头有一个大
在过去的几
十年里，一场关于
是否没有云可以简化为
知道这一点的巨大讨论，然后你再次拥有
这个和其他的背景
作为一个独立的概念，你知道
那个，以及你是否可以
将一个简化为另一个等等 所以
我认为它并不止于此，你不能
呃，即使我可以声称
其他人知道
他们
如何仍然是技术是否可以被视为的背景问题
，
无论如何这都是 我
最近也在研究
，有很多话要说，这
是一个非常有趣的想法，尤其是在
语言交流方面，它
有点像手指和月亮，
谈论月亮，但手指
只是 它在哪里，我们不是在
谈论指针，而是在
谈论参考
，因此使用
文化语言
或书面学术话语中的社会认知交流形式
来窥视或重新想象它，
甚至看到看起来的东西 就像
知道这一点的顶峰一样
，仍然把它看作知道
我猜的问题是
我们如何阅读论文
是的，当然是的
一个非常大的问题，因为如果
我们尝试将
您提到的这些负面能力视为技术问题
，似乎我们仍然会错过
一些关于沟通的东西，
另一方面，我认为这是我的
直觉，但我认为 我们
原则上可以谈论
如何
理解你刚才所说的并
试图回应它是一个
知道如何在语言上表现的问题，
但我认为即使是这种对待高水平认知主义者的运动
也让我 不是技术问题，它
仍然遗漏了一些东西
例如，以
非常充分的方式进行交流，而不是说它
不涉及现在，但这不仅
是我认为至少需要的不仅仅是
实践知识，
而且这里的关键可能是认为
实践知识只是基本的和
其他类型的必要知识 其他
类型的知识，他们
需要参与这种交流
，也许也许这是一层
至少我目前的立场是，
没有办法为我们
与世界和
其他人的接触提供基础，但在某个时刻，我们
必须能够发展其他类型的
理解来解释一个非常
解释复杂的呃
我们在日常生活中进行的交流，
例如阅读你所说的论文，
我同意我认为
框架知道作为基础，然后
恢复知道如何是一个挑战
，从基础认知过程开始也是一个挑战，
因为
没有房子和 重新组装这些
专有技术，再次知道
这不一定是一个简单的
挑战，而是我们宁愿面对
从更
阈限的
生态认知方法组装象征性命题陈述性语言等认知过程的挑战，
还是尝试从图灵中恢复生态
从某种意义上说是机器，所以
看起来
你是在支持建立
在生态合理的基础认知
过程中的基础，然后努力
组装摩天大楼
是的，是的，完全是的，我认为
这两种方法都很好
正如你所说的那样，要提供
这种呃那种
左下角或自上而下的解释，但我 我
当然更喜欢网络
方法，我认为这也是另一个
原因，它似乎从出发点来看
似乎是
对我们如何与世界互动的生物学描述，
而
相反的方式似乎要
困难得多 解释呃我们是如何
提出这个呃生物学
问题的 至少我认为
这是
一种自下而上的方法
在某种程度上更具有综合性，从某种意义上说，
它似乎更有可能
对我们有利
，而且你只是把
它框起来的方式让我觉得如果你是 要
从头开始对计算机进行编程，
它可以是抽象计算机或虚拟
计算机，因此它甚至不需要
具有特定实施例
，在这种情况下，人们可能会
关心组装
知道断言并组装
这些声明 ative
语句和逻辑处理成
更具动态性或
与环境交互的东西，但是
，像全栈工程这样的过程，
以逻辑和硅为基础，
与我们到达这里的方式完全不同
，所以它可能会，但它是
互补的，
嗯 你给了一点可见性，
嗯，我猜是在
同行评审之前和之后，所以我只是
好奇在过去的几个月或几年里
，论文期间和之后发生了什么变化，
或者
不管你在这方面是如何发展的
，然后是什么 您认为
接下来的步骤是否相关，无论它们是为您准备的还是
只是一般性的，我们是否正在
寻找大脑测量 我们是否正在
寻找森林中的摄像机 我们是否
正在寻找一个概念性的 Advance
将要向前推进的事情 你的
发展
这是一个很好的问题我想
嗯
我对
我使用外国水平的方式并不完全满意我不
知道这是否会
进行你 t in uh 老实说，我不知道
您是否可以原则上以
其他经验术语进行，但是，
我并不是说，嗯，
一个是我今天会写得有点
不同，并不是
说我不同意
最初是论文，但我想我
有一些观点我
想重新构建，但他们没有
授权，呃，我认为他有一篇新
论文，
但也许在未来，但这
是神话等问题
给出的问题 仍然是哲学
问题
和概念问题，他们仍然困扰着
我，但我还
没有找到机会
更仔细地发展这些想法以及
我在那里提出的一般观点我想我认为
它仍然存在，
但是
我想要我我 我仍然在等待
这个机会进一步阐述它，
看看我能走多远，但我还不知道
我必须承认我不知道
这个想法的未来发展是什么，
但我一直在努力 关于几个
孤立的
问题
在过去几年里，我
一直在研究
这种方法 是我喜欢如何进行
研究以找到有趣的
呃问题，看看我该如何
处理它们，但不一定会发现
自己
呃与
一种推理方式联系在一起，所以这
就是我工作时发生的事情
理性，如果我认为这
是一个非常酷的主题，嗯，我仍然
认为它是，但我还没有
时间回来重新定义我想要的
，但是，也许在
不久的将来的某个时候，我不知道，但更多
我最近一直在
做的事情不涉及细胞
理性，但我认为有些产品
可能是错误的，即
虚拟现实产品，
以及视觉现实
与 com 相比如何
因为很明显
，毅力和视觉环境中缺少一些东西，
嗯，当然，如果我有人，
例如，如果我在一个视觉
环境中，我处于一种威胁之下，
我可能会感到类似于
恐惧的东西，但是 我并没有真正担心我的
生命，
并想象虚拟现实中的人
因此
逃离威胁是合理的虚拟威胁
等等等等这就是这就是这
就是我正在工作 嗯，也许它为激进和积极理性的想法
提供了一个回归点
，事实上
，正如我在过去几天如此忙碌之前告诉你的那样，这篇论文刚刚被接受，
因为我们正在纠正
我的证明 同事和我从来没有比喻过
，我和我的
时间也很紧
，在过去几周提交论文的更正版本，然后我
得到了证明，
哦，
好吧，也许未来我
可以回到国际空间站 出于理性
我愿意，但我不知道我
是否不知道我真的无法预见它的
发展，但总的来说我
仍然同意我最初的想法，但
我会稍微改变一下 有点
所以 VR 点我敢肯定那里还有
很多话要说，但它让我
想起了虚拟现实这个标题，它是一种
虚拟化，所以就像
认知行动计划
允许我们接受
我们的身体不接受的政策一样
不要只评估它们并选择
反对它们，但我们可以继续
幻想，在心理上有一个异想天开的反事实政策
选择过程
，
但我们的形态有点像
我们的生命线，如果你真的
从窗台上掉下来，那就是 会受伤
，然后在虚拟现实中，
你体现
了知觉体验实际上
是生存危急情况的虚拟化，
所以你
可能会认为自己在窗台上，
但你在平坦的地板上
，然后在那种情况下
如果你是
电子游戏之外的认知观察者，你可能会说
，我只是停下来看看
会发生
什么是合理的 在游戏中，
嗯，所以它有点模糊
[音乐]之间
的界限，它模糊了身体的关键性
，嗯，
我相信你已经考虑过
更多了，所以这如何在我们的
虚拟现实中发挥作用
我们思考、使用
和设计这些系统的方式，
这
就是促使我们写
论文的问题，嗯，NADA 给了他们，我
是在技术文献中，你
看到很多研究人员
与 呃把呃视觉感知
当作一种幻觉，但我们对此
有点困扰，因为
另一方面它只适用于虚拟现实，因为
我们体现了他们
为我们工作的设备你有控制器你
有头 设置
，呃，说
用户处于一种幻觉之下似乎很奇怪
，另一方面，这似乎
不是真正的认知，因为正如你
所说，
与那些呃认知没有生物学相关性
可以这么说，例如，如果我
在 VR 中看到一个苹果，它不提供
营养，但它在游戏中是有道理的，
但不同的是，
我在实际环境中收到一个苹果，
它提供
营养 这是我可以吃的东西，
但不能在 VR 中我可以假装，所以我们
创造了这个 uh 暗示
它的平面的概念
uh 就好像我们
面对的是一个真正的动物，但它也涉及
这种玩的意愿这个想法
，我们不是
被误导是因为
我们在游戏中使用了我们知道的设备，
我认为这是现在的热门话题，
因为有隐喻，我
对人们非常乐观的任何事情持怀疑态度，
但
对元音的可能性持怀疑态度 rse
和一些作者真的认为我们
可以在这个
严格意义上进行模拟，但我的意思是
当前技术向我们展示的最好的技术
是它非常有限，你可以
假装在某个环境
中等等，我认为 可能会提供
一种新的思维方式来
思考这种
视觉环境中的理性，也许
俄罗斯人会做一些
环境所说的事情来跳下窗台，看看
会发生什么，另一方面
，这样做的行为方面有时
人们会真正感觉到 恐惧和人们
因对虚拟现实的恐惧而面对街头
，
嗯，这是很多，那里有很多
有趣的问题，
也许我的意思是为了未来的研究，我们可以
回到它，这让我想到
了苹果在现实生活中的表现 可能
是你的卡路里，也可能
是苍蝇的卡路里 它可以被扔掉
你可以把它当作锤子 你可以
把它画得恰到好处 所以
生态和生成 正如
我们所说的那样，一种主动推理的
过程总是超越
为给定对象编程的任何可供性，然后
嗯，当前关于 VR 的讨论主要
集中在耳机上，
只是说完全是轶事而
不是我的专业领域，
嗯，这似乎是 有点有趣
好像手机
讨论只集中在
一定大小的矩形上 是
什么让这不是虚拟现实
就像透过窗户
看到另一个人可以说话 所以
它不依附在我的头上 它不
具有某些技术所具有的一些运动
跟踪能力，
但它
是 Perry 个人空间中的一个小众修改
，我们可以将
信号和可供性相互推送，
因此拥有一个 VR 框架，或者实际上只是一个
理性和感知
认知动作的框架循环
不仅限于一种特定的
实现或硬件类型，并且可以
运行从
一个领域的总离线人员
到 s 一些
在黑客帝国中
非常重要的人似乎非常相关，否则新
技术即使是很小的变体和
软件更新也会继续
无限惊喜和困惑
是的，我认为这是一个很难
定义界限
我的意思是我们在这里呃
交换 我认为它可能会增加，但被
归类为虚拟现实的一种形式，
当然我看到你毁了你的 C
思维，
但我的意思是大多数我认为他们
现在可以解决问题，他们发现它是一个文档，
说必须有一个耳机
有时是控制器，但
除此之外听起来是虚拟现实，但是
是的，很难定义任何东西，嗯
，不是，它不是垃圾，
直截了当，这是其中的一件事，
因为在商业上，
当然虚拟现实意味着耳机
和其他用具，但是但是 在那个时候，一部
电话只是在打电话或
打电报，它本来会
在那个界面上，带有那种感官
模式和那些可供
性 虚拟
化 是的，我们今天可以访问的只是
不同的
章节 体现技术设备
是什么让我们从一
开始就使用分析技术，
以及我们可以如此
熟练地将它体现为一个设备，即使它被
编程为，例如，在
虚拟现实中，拥有一些
你控制我们的生物更富有 新
形态 例如另一种形态，
即使是这样，它也只能
如此熟练地发生，因为我们
能够体现该设备一些
实验表明，您可以
将手腕的扭转映射到
第三只手臂，
嗯，个体现实来自于
从你的胸部，人们可以
学会控制第三只手臂，
它不会映射到我们的实际形态中，
但可以通过 Twist o 来实现 f
手腕，所以
这是我们将在
我们的论文中讨论的问题，你可以
你只能这样做，因为你体现
了设备，你可以看到这是一种错觉，
这实际上
是我作为人类的一部分是
刺绣技术设备，所以
我 会这样我的意思是我知道它
模糊了虚拟
和非虚拟芽之间的区别我认为这
是处理这种
酷的一种方式你还有什么想
谈论的问或者只是一种前奏
啊我会的 非常感谢您有
机会讨论这篇论文，这
对我来说非常好，我真的很喜欢它
，这是一个非常好的和
舒适的环境来讨论这些
问题，并再次感谢你，
谢谢，是的，很棒的讨论和
重要的话题 我们很乐意
随时再次与您交谈
好的 谢谢 再见 谢谢